what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some
really really big spider-man no way home
leaks
and these come in the form of lego leaks
and
also leaked concept art for a new
spider-man suit so we have the concept
art for the new spider-man suit but the
new spider-man suit is also
shown in the lego leaks lego sets that
are supposed to go out to the public
soon but have been leaked ahead of time
now before you bat your eyes at this
this happens
a lot and they usually are pretty
revealing i remember the lego leaks for
avengers end game all ended up being
pretty much 100
true and they actually gave away the
final scene at the end where thanos
attacks the avengers compound
so just because it's a lego leak don't
brush it off they're usually pretty
revealing and this one
in particular is very revealing and for
those who are wondering if they are real
or fake
i have seen them on the actual lego site
and i did post that link on twitter for
people to see
so they are real so let's go ahead and
just jump
right into it talk about what everything
means including two new spider-man suits
and a scene where spider-man is in the
sanctum
and of course if you love the mcu and
want to stay up to date on everything
including spider-man no way home be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss any videos
so there are actually two different lego
leagues and let's go ahead and just talk
about the first one and kind of get it
out of the way because this one is a
vulture and a spider-man
drone fight now don't automatically just
go thinking that oh this is a scene
that's going to happen because as we can
see at the very top of the box here it
says
inspired by marvel studios as spider-man
homecoming so this doesn't actually
confirm that vulture is going to be in
the film and this is going to be a big
fight scene in no way home but vulture
is most likely in the movie which is why
they are releasing a lego set with him
in it
otherwise why release the lego set at
all but the big part to notice about
this one
is that spider-man seemingly has a new
suit now again this could be nothing
since it is inspired from homecoming but
maybe he does get two new suits
throughout the film because the other
lego leagues that we're about to talk
about actually do reveal a new
suit a new iron spider suit and this new
set
really is the big one to talk about this
set is not inspired by another movie it
is indeed
a set from spider-man no way home and it
does have
a lot in it now there are actually two
of peter in the sanctum and mj is there
as well
and one actually looks pretty peaceful
peter is on some type of a bike
doctor strange has a wrench in his hand
so it looks like they're trying to fix
the bike
his cloak is flying behind spider-man
wong is on the computer and it looks
like mj also has a wrench or some type
of tool in her hand as well
now we knew doctor strange was going to
be in spider-man no way home we knew
that he was going to be somewhat of a
mentor to peter parker
however perhaps he's not so much of a
mentor to peter parker than we thought
he was
now obviously with peter parker's
identity being revealed that he is
indeed spider-man he needed a place to
stay and what better place to stay
than the sanctum now of course doctor
strange and peter fought together an
infinity war and end game so i'm sure
doctor strange
doesn't mind helping him out especially
when you consider that the multiverse
and the spider-verse are going to be a
big part of no way home
doctor strange is definitely going to be
able to provide some help to peter
in that aspect because that's what
doctor strange does that's what he knows
so yes doctor strange will be a little
bit of a mentor to peter parker but i
don't think peter is just going to be
relying on doctor strange the entire
film which is what a lot of fans were
kind of upset about they want to see
peter finally on his own and i think
that's what we'll see
i simply think that doctor strange is
simply providing a place for peter to
hide
and trying to help him with the whole
identity crisis then from there i think
the multiverse blows up
and peter and doctor strange might kind
of part ways because strange is going to
have to deal with a lot and peter is
going to have to deal with a lot as well
and then of course as we all expect the
other spider-man are going to jump in
but let's continue to look at this lego
league because
the other version shows something very
different than the peaceful scene that
we saw in the first one
the second version shows a lot of chaos
and it looks like there is some type
of mechanical scorpion being attacking
them i'm going to assume this is
scorpion
because it's green and it has the
pincers and it just looks like a
scorpion
and it looks like scorpion is actually
going to attack
the sanctum in this we can actually see
that he's kind of managed to capture
wong we see spider-man is hanging on the
wall shooting a web at scorpion doctor
strange
seems to have just come through a portal
and it looks like even mj is involved in
this battle somehow looks like she's
carrying
some type of candles in her hand but we
don't know the actual context of the
scene perhaps she is simply
trying to run away and hide because if
this scorpion has captured wong then
mj is in pretty big trouble and doesn't
really stand a chance but luckily
spider-man is there and doctor strange
is there as well
now this actually poses a pretty big
question and i think this falls back to
a leak that we heard
about a couple of months ago that really
ties everything together but first let's
talk about that new suit
spider-man has a little bit of a new
suit and it does look like it's somewhat
of a combination of
his iron spider suit and another suit it
actually kind of looks like the iron
spider suit from the civil war comics as
paul from heavy spoilers pointed out on
twitter
now spider-man has pretty much gotten a
new suit in each film that we've seen so
far
so we would be foolish to not expect him
to get a new suit in this film however
this suit seems like it is simply the
iron spider suit and perhaps a little
bit more technology is put on it or
perhaps maybe even some type of magical
spell from doctor strange
clearly in these leagues they are
working on some mechanical pieces
perhaps it's not just the bike that they
were working on perhaps it's a suit as
well
and also happy could very much still be
in the picture and i do expect to see
him in spider-man no way home
so another option is that he simply got
an upgraded iron spider suit from happy
tony stark was notorious for making
multiple different versions of
essentially the same suit but each with
their own
little different tweak so he probably
made more than one
iron spider suit for peter parker so it
definitely looks like peter is going to
be getting a new
upgraded suit in no way home but as i
mentioned
there also seems to be some concept art
leaked of the new
suit and as we can see here it looks
pretty dang cool it definitely has a lot
more gold on it in fact the emblem on
the chest
is entirely gold and this definitely
looks more like the civil war suit that
we got from the comics
now this actually looks pretty similar
to some concept art that we got for the
iron spider suit for avengers infinity
war however
it is different as we can see here and
this new suit looks absolutely
incredible so we can't expect the iron
spider suit to return
in no way home now as i mentioned before
about the lego leaked
scene it's a pretty big deal the fact
that scorpion is in the sanctum
is kind of baffling the sanctum is very
heavily protected
it's not like they just let random bad
guys walk in or burst in it's protected
by magic
yes the hulk came crashing through the
window but he was also sent there by the
bifrost which is magic so either it's
getting attacked pretty heavily and
we're only seeing scorpion here but
there could be
other people with him or perhaps he
attacked from the inside
there was a plot leak that said doctor
strange was actually holding
some multiversal enemies in some type of
magical prison
in the sanctum this leak did say that
peter parker was hiding out in the
sanctum but then he
accidentally or intentionally releases
these villains so this
is also an option perhaps they are
attacking from the inside because they
got out of their prison cell which
doctor strange was keeping them in
or perhaps somehow they got a portal
through and entered that way either way
it's very interesting that
scorpion although it is a giant machine
of a scorpion got inside
perhaps the scorpion mech is extremely
powerful with a lot of firepower and
that's how it got in but let's not rule
out the fact that it could have attacked
from the inside
and this could be a scorpion from a
different
universe now i know scorpion was set up
in spider-man homecoming but that
doesn't necessarily
mean that he's going to return marvel
has set people up before to have them
not really show up
and this is a multiverse movie so you
never really know
now what i would love to see happen is
that whether or not this is scorpion
from our universe or another universe
this mech this technology this huge
scorpion suit that he's been provided
i really wanted to be provided to him by
norman osborne he is said to be
the main villain of spider-man no way
home and if all of these other villains
are attacking spider-man it would be
really cool if norman osborne was kind
of providing them with the means to be
able to catch him
essentially funding a sinister six but
we'll have to wait and see what is
actually going on
however these leaks can hold us over in
the meantime before we get that first
trailer so let me know what you think
about these in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest spider-man videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me